si tú tuvieras que pedir dinero prestado
para diferentes cantidades de tiempo
puedes imaginar que la persona que te
presta el dinero que cobrará diferentes
tasas de interés dependiendo del riesgo
que tiene el dinero prestado por cada
cantidad de tiempo y lo mismo pasa
cuando la gente presta dinero al
gobierno federal así que cuando pensamos
en la tesorería de tu país ésta tiene
distintas fechas de vencimiento que no
es ni más ni menos que en cuánto tiempo
la tesorería te devolverá tu dinero de
regreso y por lo tanto de esto va a
depender el interés o el rendimiento que
se te pagará como estamos suponiendo que
son varios préstamos cada uno con sus
distintas fechas de vencimiento
entonces los podemos graficar así que
vamos a suponer que la primera deuda que
tiene la tesorería contigo se va a pagar
dentro de un mes tiene de fecha de
vencimiento un mes y si nos fijamos en
el dinero que prestamos al gobierno
contra el dinero que nos regresará el
gobierno en la fecha del vencimiento
podemos obtener el rendimiento y vamos a
suponer que es del 1 por ciento ahora
bien la segunda deuda va a ser en tres
meses va a tener una fecha de
vencimiento en tres meses con un
rendimiento del 1.5
vamos a tener una tercera deuda que se
va a pagar dentro de un año y esta tiene
una tasa de rendimiento más grande del
3% el gobierno te debe una cuarta deuda
que se va a pagar dentro de diez años
tiene una fecha de vencimiento de diez
años y esta va a tener una tasa de
interés más grande va a ser del 3.5 por
ciento y para finalizar vamos a suponer
que también hay una deuda que se va a
pagar en 30 años tiene una fecha de
vencimiento de 30 años con una tasa de
interés del 4% así que ya con esto
tenemos las fechas de vencimiento las
tasas de interés o el rendimiento y
entonces como grafica mos esta
información y ya con esto le vamos a dar
vida a la curva del rendimiento en la
paz se va a medir en pesos según la
cantidad de valores y de bonos que
tenemos de la tesorería y esta curva de
rendimiento es una herramienta que
podemos utilizar cuando tenemos una
comparación de deudas en cualquier
momento no sé por ejemplo en algún bueno
corporativo o por cada valor del
gobierno o por cada valor de una
corporación de otro país o lo que se nos
ocurra y consta de dos ejes en el eje x
o en el eje de las artistas vamos a
poner la fecha de vencimiento
una de nuestras deudas y como ya tenemos
también las fechas de vencimiento
entonces vamos a ponerlas de una buena
vez aquí va a ser un mes y aquí por lo
tanto van a ser tres meses y no mejor lo
voy a borrar y los voy a pegar un poco
más porque entonces la escala no me va a
quedar nada real voy a suponer que aquí
es un mes y aquí son tres meses estoy
intentando hacer lo mejor que se pueda
mi escala sé que va a quedar una escala
muy rara pero bueno aquí va a ser un año
aquí cinco años y bueno no son diez años
esto es mejor lo borro voy a hacer
crecer un poco más mi eje de las equis y
aquí voy a suponer que son diez años y
aunque la escala está muy rara voy a
suponer que lo más lejos que se pueda en
este eje de asx lo más lejos que se
pueda y que también se ve en la pantalla
vas a hacer 30 años estas escalas están
un poco raras yo lo sé pero estoy
haciendo lo mejor posible y bueno en el
eje de las 10 voy a poner las tasas de
interés o el rendimiento entonces voy a
suponer que mi valor más grande es 4 % y
entonces en un mes es 1 % que es aquí en
tres meses tengo 1.5 por ciento que va a
ser por aquí en un año tengo una tasa de
interés con un rendimiento del 3
entonces es 1 2 3 va a ser justo por acá
en 10 años va a subir hasta el 3.5 por
ciento entonces vamos a ponerlo bien
aquí es 1.5 por ciento
este es un 1 por ciento y en 10 años es
el 3.5 por ciento está arriba del 3
abajo del 4 entonces tengo que ponerlo
aquí este va a ser mi tasa de interés
con mi rendimiento del 3.5 por ciento y
por último cuando yo tengo una deuda o
cuando yo le prestó el banco durante 30
años una cierta cantidad de dinero yo
obtengo una tasa interés del 4% y ya
está si nosotros unimos dos puntos vamos
a obtener la curva de rendimiento que
voy a intentar dibujar un poco mejor y
que se ve más o menos así y para
finalizar lo que podemos ver es que si
le prestamos dinero a la tesorería por
un largo periodo de tiempo vamos a
obtener una tasa de interés o un
rendimiento mayor al rendimiento que
obtendríamos en un periodo de tiempo más
corto